[Music]
a class reunion for Laguna Beach High
School
[Music]
you're coming back to where it all
started fans have Kristen Cavallari to
thank for this nostalgic photo shoot
celebrating a throwback jewelry line
from her company uncommon James wow
[Music]
probably wouldn't exist if it weren't
for I built-in audience from the TV
shows that I've done so thankful that I
have this built-in audience and these
people have been with me since I was
like 17 years old for like 2 million
people on television and stuff that's
not really and we're hearing the cast
had the best time on set the source
tells E.T they loved reminiscing about
their days on reality TV our senior year
in Laguna Beach wasn't exactly going
smoothly the video kicks off with
Kristen's meat cute with ex-boyfriend
Stephen colletti
[Music]
of course the pair sees each other
plenty
there's moments we're not proud of well
I have some regrets I can think of a
couple they host a re-watch podcast back
to the beach reliving their highs and
lows on the MTV series that chronicled
the lives of Orange County teenagers in
the mid-2000s
hey do you want to go to a Blink 182
concert with me tomorrow night
a lot of fun it's a lot of fun you know
like she's great to hook up with Lauren
would be a better girlfriend okay that's
what I said okay well I think at this
point our relationship we probably have
broken up uh two or three times already
yeah it's been therapeutic it's just
been all the things I'm really having a
good time am I supposed to be really
happy to see you or something well we
are happy to see the gang get back
together in 2023 including Jason Waller
Talent toriero Alex Morrell Alex Hooser
and Jessica Smith
[Music]
ET Source adds that it was like No Time
had passed for the OC crew
ain't nothing gonna hold you back
[Music]
foreign
I mean I use denzo with you today and I
was like oh my God I love it so much my
car is dunzo if only I had trademarked
that back in the day so while Laguna
Beach may have premiered nearly 20 years
ago we'll never be done so with these
wide 2K era Legends
[Music]
ain't nothing going
on
[Music]